[Music]
it's rolling one two three tests it's
good for the sound let's do this
[Music]
Ancestors is not about unfolding the
mission we've put up there for you you
your curiosity that is driving the show
because in ancestors the humankind
Odyssey there is no mini-map and there
is no map at all it wasn't important for
us that the player is actually again the
the one mapping the one discovering the
one exploring and have us helping
through that journey to that Odyssey a
lot and you'll have to really actually
go down into your instinct in order to
play the game more you're curious and
you test a new experiment you'll see the
game opening up for you I get surprised
by the game every single time I play
because I'm trying new stuff it's a game
there's still boundaries right but you
can go pretty much anywhere you want
we've created a world for you right and
then you're kind of like the co-creators
of the experience just like everything
is kind of like there and it's up to you
to be curious and find what's in it
[Music]
each time I do an action I'm asking some
energy and the more action I do quickly
eventually that energy is spent and it
will tap into the stamina of the
character you have to do eat drink and
sleep those are the three core elements
for your survival and once you sleep for
at least four hours we'll update your
daily regimen that will you will gain
back your stamina and your energy
throughout the games will have different
encounters with with dangers and you can
get attacked they can attack each other
which is good for you by the way
if you're being pursued by a leopard and
he sees an antelope
maybe the lunch of the leopard is the
antelope and not you be careful and what
you put in your mouth I would say in
general you may be poisoned what is kind
of good in general but food you never
know and you can die by falling be
careful in some of the rivers just you
know you can slip for example also
there's a lot of things that can kill
you but we will never give you the
solution it's up to you to experiment
and then you need to go through bad
times in order to have good time I was
saying
and like Callaghan said right extinction
is the norm survival is the exception so
you're gonna play really in an
environment that wants to kill you
there's really dangers around every
corner
[Music]